me
はいえーと私が
ほとんど目が見えなくなってから15年以上になります今日はえーどうもみなさんに
こんな私から
視覚以外の感覚でどうやって
見ているのかをお伝えしたいと思います
まず最初にですね皆さん目を閉じてください
今何が聞こえていますか
私の声が動いていると思います他にもそうですね
動くなに書く人が動いて
たら洋服が擦れる音とか
そういった音が聞こえている方もいらっしゃると思いますでは次にですね目を閉じか
まぁ皆さんの右手でご自身の左手を触って観察してみてください
小指の根つめのそれぞれの爪の形ですとか
ペダ悪い
大きさ違うなって感じている方もいらっしゃるだろう c
こうなんか定期長はきょうは体の血管の浮いてるダーって
を触って感じる方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
入るは今度目あげてください
次はですね皆さんにこの水の入った卓球玉の音を耳で追いかけていただきたいなと思い
ます
いろんなところから多分ほどことが来ると思うので目を閉じて
へと聞いてみてください
8 d わかっ
安里さんにそれ取ります取ります投げ返して
ありがとうございます
今度はもう一つ
別の亡霊
同じように鈴が入っています今度はこっちの音を聴いていただきたいなと思います
じゃあまた目をつぶってボールの音を追いかけてみてくださいこれ誰か
お願いできますか
半日止めるオープの雷神キャッチャー誰か目開けてとってもらいます
詰めた星ケア
はい
ありがとうございますん
じゃあ皆さん目開けてくださいえーと今皆さん
目を閉じてボールの音を追いかけてもらったと思うんですけれども
8視覚以外の感覚を使って
今のようにこう
もうボールの音をタッチする search するっていうことを
視覚障害の目の見えない人たちは行っていますその中でも今の感覚
皆さんに感じていただいた感覚をフルに活用した
8を
ゴールゴールというスポーツがあります
ご存知のない方もいらっしゃると思うので江戸映像をご覧下さい
nuna
car
投げる
dee
ハムいいの
達ボールな試合は12分になる
あれもうと同じ広さのコートの中で13年のプレイヤーがそれぞれ自陣のゴールの前で
プレイボス
ic 度という女が苦笑し完全に見えない
コードラインの下の凹凸を頼りに
5地消を確認しながら
しづ入ったボールを転がして音を頼りに奪い合う
denham
ええええええ
ana
me
4日が入った
ポジションを入れ替えたりし程度相手オファーさん
合流ええええ
近く入院の観客を取り済ませていると戦うスポーツなんか
はいということで今ご覧頂きましたかアティ全く見えない状態でええええゲームをし
ます今日はこの日あこれあげていただいたボールこれがボールボールのボールです
そして選手がつけていた ap ai
シェードという目隠しが持ってきているのでえっと実際にステージ上べ
ここにありましたん
いかに会制度があっ
ございましたすいません i 制度という目隠しを持ってきているので実際にステージ
上で転がしあってみたいなと思いますパトリックってください
あっはいパトリックさんよろしくお願いします
フェリエシーズ
ok これが目指す子です具合の方ですねそれをつけていただいて
hers
良い子 z 今から転がしますので暴動を撮ってみてくださいいきます
そうねん
第9 f
登録くださいはいあ
入ってません
もう1回行きまー八景
ん
うううう壊れてますはい
ありがとうございまーすっ
ございましたどーもっす
はいありがとうございました次は何でしょうかね
を楽しんでいただけたみたいで嬉しいいる江戸今3のように視覚オス全く使わないで
あの音だけで
場所を判断したりします
ねこうして後皆さんには先ほど目を閉じていただきましたが目を閉じるだけでいつも
感じているものとちょっと見えてる時に感じていることと時とまぁ違う感覚を得られ
たりとか
普段傷から気付かが良い音やヘはいとかですね
そういったものを感じることができ
ます
江戸水ねそういった8見えないからこそ感じることっていうのが高
ゴールボールやしかつ目を閉じることで感じることができています
どコース抵抗まあこのオールボールというのはパラリンピックの種目でもあるんです
けれども
パラリー2020年東京パラリンピックありますがその頃にはまあ障害を持った方々が
たくさんへと東京に日本にいますその時に講師抵抗視覚障害を持っていても他の障害を
持っていてもこうしてあん
の自分たちの能力を発揮して8自分達どエイドを個性として
lobos 目スポーツを楽しんでいる方々もいっぱいいると思っています
ぜひね皆さんも8その感覚お米を閉じるだけでも感じられると思いますのでぜひ感じて
みてもらいたいなと思います
そして今日はへと先ほどエイドを見せたあの i 制度
目隠しをいくつか持ってきているので
ええええ
もしこの中であの目隠しをして食事をしてみたいなーという方がいらっしゃいますから
あのランチの時間にぜひ私のところに来て
目学習すて一緒にあのランチをしていただきたいなと思っていますのでぜひお越し
ください
どうもありがとうございました